Hey, what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and It's time for the
Monday morning podcast for Monday.
Fucking June 27th June.
What stuff? What happened
to this month? My goodness.
Where's it going? You know what? I
think July 18th. That's my half day.
July 18th I think we'll be wrapped.
We'll be done with the writing of the
10 episodes of efforts for family.
Then all we gotta do is look
at the drawings and edit
them for the next fucking
10 months. But the heavy
lifting will be out of the way.
Um, would you guys like to know
on an animated show works well?
You sit in a room and you come
up with fucking whatever. Yeah.
You have figured out how the
whole season is going to go.
Then you fucking write it and then
it changes like 50 fucking times.
You rewrite, you rewrite, you
rewrite your record, you write more,
you do table reads, you
do all his fucking shit.
Then once you get all of that done,
what starts coming in as the animatics,
which is basically the rough
drawings of a, of the shit,
you know that you recorded and
then you say, ah, well you know,
why is he standing next to that chair?
He should be over in the kitchen.
You've got to do all of that
shit. He's not moving enough.
Have him take his glasses off
their of heaven. Fucking be.
You got to do all of that.
And then they fucking draw it and then
you look at it and then it still might
not be funny. And then you gotta be
like, all right is what we wrote.
Not Funny or is the way it's
executed here? Not Fun in that.
That's why it takes so fucking long in
case you wondering, cause you're like,
well shit, you recorded.
I mean you wrote them.
Why don't they just take out some magic
markers and fucking put them on a piece
of paper?
And then somebody stands there and they
flip through it like they used to in the
old days. So they used to do, they'd
have somebody, a the village idiot,
go up on stage with a giant fucking
notebook and he'd sit there going
from just going through the thing and
people would sit there and they enjoy it
and the guy screwed up. They A,
they shot him cause
everybody had guns back then.
At least that's the way
it was in America. Um,
speaking of America,
what's going on in Ireland,
I decided I was going to start looking
to see what the fuck is going on in these
countries and we're
going to be going to, uh,
evidently might know Neil Martin O'Neill,
the Republic of Ireland's Martin
O'Neill there, there, Bill Belicheck.
He was fucking pissed because Ireland
just lost to France in some game where
you're not allowed to pick the ball up
with your hands for whatever fucking
recent, you know,
you'd figure if you're only allowed
to use your feet or your hands,
or let's say you use your
fucking hands. I mean,
there's no style of fighting where
you just use your feet, right.
Maybe taekwondo, but they didn't, you
know, if you fucking come at them,
they're still gonna Punch you in the
nose, right? I just don't understand it.
I'm fucking with you. It's
actually, it's a beautiful game.
I went in to get my head fucking
shaved the other day. Right now.
What to this blob
of shop? A real barber shop when?
Where you walk in and there's
fucking men in there, right?
Rubbing their hairy
chest. And I'm kidding.
There's men in there and you just fucking
go at and you sit down until it's your
fucking turn. Unlike these fucking
Goddamn hips to fucking things,
whether they got the little fucking,
what do you call that barbershop?
Little swivel thing that goes around to
me that says I can just walk in. Right?
And then you walk in again. There's
nobody here. Can you shake my head?
I'll do Hilton appointment. Dude. Look
at me. How long is it gonna fucking take?
You want to make an extra
fucking 20 bucks? Huh? You don't,
I can go fuck yourself. You know,
you fucking 28th president of the
United States fucking haircut.
Who is that by the way?
Who is the 28th president?
Nobody ever talks about the
28th presidents. Let's look
it up. Let's look it up.
Uh, 28 president. You know,
if I, if I had to guess,
I'm going to say Grover
Cleveland, uh, 28th,
President Calvin Coolidge,
the Fuck Oh, oh, oh,
the content itself. Woodrow
Wilson, Woodrow Wilson,
who signed the fucking
Federal Reserve Act and uh,
and we're all still paying
for it today. You know,
it's a good one to look up
Woodrow Wilson's letter of regret.
What are the fucking odds I would've
said that sent me down this conspiracy
theory. Woodrow Wilson Letter of regret.
All right, where is it?
Where is did Wilson w did Woodrow
Wilson regret handing America
to the Federal Reserve? Woodrow Wilson,
after creating the Federal Reserve,
said, uh, let's see. Here we go.
I have unwittingly ruined my country. I
don't know how to pronounce that word,
so maybe he didn't. All right. This is
what he wrote. I am a most unhappy man.
I have unwittingly,
unwittingly ruined my country.
A great industrial nation is
controlled by its system of credit.
Our system of credit is concentrated.
See, they always got to write it.
So sophisticated.
Sophisticatedly I can't even understand
what the fuck they're talking about.
Like that thing, Dwight d Eisenhower,
when he gives that speech about the
industrial military complex itch,
I watched that over and over again.
I have no fucking idea
what he's talking about.
Even it's explained to me before I
watched the speech and by the end of it I,
I don't understand it and I feel like he
said it that way either because he was
so fucking smart. He couldn't
relate to the common man,
which I don't understand because he had
all those soldiers or he said it that
way because he had to say it in a
way that he wouldn't get off. Right.
I don't fucking know. Anyways, he said
the growth of the nation, therefore,
and all our activities are in the hands
of a few men. This is a president.
A former president wrote this. Okay, so
I don't want to hear any guys saying,
oh conspiracy, go fuck yourself.
It's just like when I told you that the
NBA was fixed and then there was the
mobbed up ref and you guys all tried to
wiggle out of it. And what did they say?
Oh yeah, there was just one
of them. Oh yeah. Was there,
there was just one of them.
All right, we have to come too.
We have come to be one
of the worst, ruled,
one of the most completely
controlled and dominated,
govern governments in the civilized world.
Lone longer a government by free opinion.
No longer a government by conviction
and the vote of the majority,
but a government by the opinion and
duress of a small group of dominant men.
Oh, there you go. He still didn't
quite fucking say what he did.
Um,
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Oh God. They got, they got fucking,
you know what they did Woodrow?
They put woody from cheers.
Their version of chairs or their
version of woody from fucking chairs.
They put them in the office. Well,
what am I even talking about right now?
I didn't want to talk about
this. I was talking about soccer.
How the fuck do I go from
soccer to that? So anyways,
it's Martin O'Neill who I would not fuck
with some of it at an Irish brogue in
those fucking glasses, you
know, you know, just some,
somehow we teach Xapi to the throat. Um,
he said they got the short end short
straw when they played France for whatever
fucking reason. I never
even finished the story.
So I wanted to get my
fucking head shaped. And a,
they had that European champion was
championship, was on the highlights,
the whole fucking thing. Everybody
in there was into the game.
So I automatically got into
it. So, oh, hope you guys know,
I'm just fucking with you
when it comes to that.
It's just that when the world
loves something as a comedian,
it's just so easy to make fun of it
and to get the feedback that you want,
which is totally people losing their
minds typing at you and all capital
letters. It's just fun. Um, so anyways,
for some reason France got an extra three
days to rest their tired legs in their
swollen feet before they got to play
the little footy game again in Ireland.
Didn't like it. You know,
it's funny, the guy,
the guy like trashes them
and says, uh, you know,
we got fucked over three days is
an incredible amount of time. Uh,
one side could have as an
advantage over another, uh,
Blahblahblahblahblah that said,
France friends who are really,
really fine team and good luck to them
and the tournament. I love that shit.
After you fucking trash him. I'm just
completely unfair. Go Fuck Yourself.
But I haven't said that out.
You've got a hell of a team now.
[inaudible] good shot.
Chia. Matey alright.
Irish news headlines March
going on in Ireland. Roy Foster,
Britton Co's signed a
margins by this stupid party.
I don't know what that means. Mary
Robinson is, that's not a real name.
Mary Robinson.
Okay.
Is that an alias? [inaudible]
Brexit could have a domino
effect. What the fuck is Brexit?
Isn't this shit Trump got in trouble for,
that's what I loved about Trump this week.
When he fucking went to
Scotland and it, yeah, just like
Scotland, we're going to
take our country back.
Cause I guess Scotland was voting about
whether they still wanted to be a part
of the European Union and uh,
Scotland overwhelmingly agreed to
stay part of it. Evidently, I dunno.
And Trump went there and didn't know it.
And I was reading like what everyone
was saying and it was, you know,
trashing Donald Trump.
And it was so similar to what
people write to me every week. John,
Sally isn't dead. You fucking moron.
I said the wrong name. I didn't mean
John. Sally, you know what? What do,
what do you want from me? All
right. A former president,
president or what?
Yeah,
Mary Robinson. She was
president of Ireland.
You know what? She's a lovely
lady. I'd vote for her when the,
when the fuck was she
president, former president.
Mary Robinson has said that young people
in the UK must feel very let down by
the outcome of the Brexit
Brexit modal referendum.
And she appealed to the EU
to remember its core values.
One of the vague shit that
she say, Jesus Christ,
can you help out an American here?
What the fuck's going on
over there and that crisis,
there's some bullshit I have
to know when I go over there
some sort of referendum.
Should the United Kingdom remain a
member of the European Union or leave the
European Union? What's going on with the
European Union, the EU? What happens?
You guys formed a super group, but now
all the egos are getting in the way.
What happened?
How Greece is fucking economy went down
and all of a sudden it's fucking with
you guys. You'll never do that.
Never join a fucking group.
Take it from a complete loner who does
stand up, right? You don't join a group.
You know what I mean? You use the group,
okay, what do you guys do? Oh yeah,
you cater parties. All
right, I'm having a party.
I don't want to join your party operation.
I'd like you to come over here and a
Tyson balloons to some fucking lampposts.
Could you do that and how much would that
cost and here's your check and get out
of my life. That's how you do it.
Why the fuck would you go, hey,
it's actually amazing that they
got it done. You know what I mean?
Considering all the fucking wars
they've had over the years, you know?
Yeah.
Fascism, communism, fucking,
whatever the fuck we're called.
I don't know what the fuck we are.
Okay.
How the fuck did they do all that
and why did they do all that?
That just all comes down to bankers.
What was wrong with having the pound and
then the fucking Ireland had this Shell
Ailey, right? What they have in Sweden,
I don't know what the fuck they had.
Some sort of thing. A leg of that
design the way a little shrinker.
I don't fucking know.
I don't understand why everybody has
to get in bed with everybody yelling.
It's going to be better. It's going
to create more jobs. No, it isn't. No,
it isn't. It's just going to make the
people at the top make more fucking money.
It's just like, you know, can we
have more people to fuck in the ass?
Can we have some of your people? What
a, if we would, if we combined
all the people, right?
We fucking microchipped them.
We phased out fucking money.
What if we did that right? And now, yeah,
everything's on your little
microchip here, right?
People getting mugged in the future.
It's going to be fucking hilarious.
It's going to be some fucking nerdy kid
getting dragged in by a football player
and you're going to grab a bunch of Dr
Peppers and some fucking Sag nut bars,
and then they're going to grab the nerds
risks and fucking just keep swiping it,
making them pay for all this shit, right?
If you're fucking rich, you're gonna.
You can't even go out
of the fucking house.
Someone's going to grab you and take
you to a Lexus dealership. Civil fucking
grabbed the guy. Just fucking, just
start scanning. Oh, that'd be great.
You know, it's not going
happen. They're gonna have,
you're gonna have like 50 men. Oh my God.
This is this going to be some
shit going down. If you get,
if you're going to have a microchip in
your fucking body that has every fucking
cent you ever earned, that you didn't
blow on fucking bud lights and hookers,
you know, doesn't that make you like,
what's going to stop somebody from just
coming up and just sucker punching you
and then carving your fucking
microchip out of your arm? Right.
And then it's like they got an extra
life and then they just have this fucking
thing and they just start
running around with tweezers,
just scanning a bunch of
shit. Why wouldn't they just,
you know what they're gonna do? They'll
fucking chop your arm off, right?
And then fucking hide
your body. Okay. You know,
like how they used to do
that, like allegedly the, uh,
the Westies,
they chop some guy's arm off and then
they would go around committing murders
and then they'd take the arm out of the
fridge and they put the fingerprints on
the gun and then they just put
the arm back in the fridge. It's,
if you get past the
fucking humanity, you know,
it's really brilliant and slash
borderline fucking hilarious.
Um, man, I bet those guys could
tell a story. Jesus Christ,
you know the shit they did.
Horrible Shit. But Jesus,
you have to be a funny
Bastien on some fucking level.
I know you're out of your mind,
but there is something fucking
hilarious about that. You know?
And then the cops, you know, when they
were drinking, the cops are just like,
that's fucking guy struck again. You
know, they will laugh and go, dude,
you realize we're
inventing a serial killer.
And they'd all be sitting there laughing
their balls off and then at some point
the laughter would died down is that
they then realize like, wait a minute,
where we're kind of serial
killers. Well, we're all doing it.
It's a group effort. You know, it's not
like it's one person. So yeah. You know,
whatever, go to another Jamieson. Um,
anyways,
I have no fucking idea what I'm talking
about and I have no idea what's going on
in the world and I evidently I need to
learn it. I need to learn it before,
you know, I go to Scotland, they start
handing up, fuck those signs. You know,
Trump is a cunt. I just all of that Shit,
Donald Trump is fucking,
he's back to being fucking hilarious
again to me because I know he's not going
to win. He's not gonna win. The
whole world can fucking relax.
Everybody knows Hillary's
getting in. Okay.
And what's funny is everybody's
going to relax, relax. Like, oh,
thank God we dodged that fucking bullet.
Like Hillary isn't a fucking bankers
wet dream coming down like a fucking
freight train. Um, now cheesy.
She better not get elected.
I'm getting a fucking audited. Do you
want to times I've trashed her. Oh my God.
Oh God. That fucking, ugh.
Some of the Shit I want to say.
I can't fucking say it because
in this day and age, you just,
you just cannot say that.
You understand why a certain
person did what he did.
Um,
age is Christ just coming home to that
fucking air raid siren every fuck he can.
He at least fucking, you know,
doll yourself up a little bit.
Jesus Christ with the fucking the paper
chase. Look over here. I mean, what,
what, what, what was the guy's
supposed to do? I'm just kidding.
Bill Clinton would fuck a hole in a tree
and he would do it with his
fucking pants down with this,
the fucking secret service standing
with their backs to them like five feet
away. They could literally film,
don't feel the wind of his hips
as he was pumping the tree.
Guys at Animal Day in and fucking day out,
that guy is a fucking animal. God
blow. You know what? God bless him.
God bless him. You know,
it's just how he's wired.
Did you guys ever see
that episode of cheaters?
Remember that show they'd
catch people cheating, right?
And that lady cut the fuck. Can anybody
find this clip from me? This Liz Lady,
a southern Belle. She catches her
fucking redneck guy stepping out on it,
right? And this fucking guy, she, you
know, he was supposed to be embarrassed,
but he was hammered.
She usually like, oh my God, if I can
pacy shit, I could cheat. Dude is cheese,
you know, slap rat fuckin two
dudes. And he goes, well honey,
did it ever dawn on you?
Then maybe just maybe I was tired of
fucking you and I wanted to fuck someone
else
and he said it. The wiz delivery of
that epic line was just, it was like,
he was saying like, like hello, you know,
fucking get your shit together.
The fucking answers right here.
Like he said, it was such, he was
putting it on her. It was one of the,
one of the,
one of the more amazing things I've
seen a human being do in that situation,
you know what I mean? Um, anyways,
let me get back to the fucking,
what's going on here in Scotland?
What's going on here? Oh, by the
way, uh, so Belgium has been added.
Germany has been added even
though, you know, I'm making,
I think that paying me, like
with a couple of steins of beer,
which I don't give a fuck. I just
want to go over there. I want to,
I'm that close. You know,
I'm going to do Germany,
some weird fucking town I never heard of.
And then I'm driving over to
Belgium and I'm not doing a,
what the fuck was the fucking capital
of Brussels? I don't, fuck it wasn't,
no, it is Brussels, right? A
Belgium, Brussels, right. Sorry,
I'm doing like 20 things here.
I just realized I never found out who
the fuck Mary robins were. Jesus Christ.
She must've been a great, she looks
honest as the fucking days long.
Maddie. Robyn said, if I production,
I didn't always tell you
she's cute as a button,
but I wouldn't want to cross hair.
That fucking shit. Any field.
Is that what you guys said over there?
What the fuck is his Shalala bill?
You don't know. All right.
Mary Robinson. Mary,
Mary, Mary. Oh, Jesus. That's
an unfortunate fucking picture.
Jesus Christ. Has she ever
used conditioner in our life?
Her fucking hair. It looks
like the Hollywood hills.
Right before they catch on fire.
Did the Santa Ana winds come out
of her fucking hairdryer? Oh,
I thought she was dead.
She's not dead. Is she
in office from 1969 to
1989 she's 72 years old.
She's got three kids. Wait a
minute away. Married three same
[inaudible] I eight ish,
born at 20 fish that made 1844
he never back Amish intellect.
I don't have time to read all
of this presidency. All right.
Open the fucking link account.
Robinson was inaugurated as the seventh
president of Ireland under the well,
how many fucking dumb along to you stay
in office seven presidents since caveman
days.
She proved a remarkably popular president
earning the praise of Brian Linehan
himself. Well, shit, if Brian
says it well then fuck you know,
before his death, five years later,
sorry, Brian in the Linehan film. Uh,
so that she was a better president
than he ever could have been. Oh,
that was the guy that went
after your can let fucking hire.
All right. I'm Saturday.
She was great. Uh,
that was every fucking I
accident over there. Okay.
She took an office that had a reputation
as being little more than a retirement
position for a prominent politician
and breathed new life into the road.
How is that a retirement position?
You're president of Ireland. Oh God.
I got some questions
when I get over there.
Okay.
Brian fucking Linehan. Let's see what
Brian Lee lend a hand look like. Yes,
we get oldies.
You really want to see what people
look like to figure out why they died.
Brian Linehan.
Okay,
Brian, Linda, and let's see what it
looks like. Let's see the old, give me a,
Ah, you fucking in
shape. Cons. Come on man.
You supposed to have
the heart attack face.
Okay.
Oh, that's not the guy.
Cleo, did you just fart?
Who that? Well, hang on a
second. What the fuck is,
what the fuck is the guy's name? Man.
Brian Linehan. He died five-year.
They actually, the guy just
looked up was from Canada. I got,
I still have a chance
here that this guy was a,
Oh my God.
Do I have to hit fucking pause to find
this again? All right. Presidency,
Brian Lynn Ad. All right,
there it is. Brian Lenahan.
Come on. You can't Ireland. Hey or didn't.
40 Amber Day.
Okay, there we go. Okay.
Let's see what this fucking did. Son
of a bitch. Oh, there it is. Oh yeah,
that's a heart attack face. If I
ever saw, I'm saying heart attack,
I'm going heart attack.
He died on my birthday was
an Irish and a barrister.
What the fuck is that? Does that
mean he sings while he tends bar a
death? Just get to death.
Died. Okay. Die Dead. Oh God.
This spending up your disease. Come
on. I say heart attack. Heart attack.
Nice and quick. Pancreatic
cancer. 52. Fuck.
I'm to 48. Jesus Christ.
All right, let's get off
this fucking subject. Uh,
Micah Dolan says to the Lenahan
family anyways, it's such a fucking,
it's the fucking worst. I got a buddy
of mine. I, this is something too,
I'm going to be doing a
sh a benefit coming up.
I just had to figure out
how to put it together. Uh,
I got a really good friend of mine.
His wife just got cancer for the second
time and dig in fucking buried in bills.
So, um,
I'm gonna put together a
show out here in La and uh,
you know, all the proceeds are going to
go to that. That's fucking all right.
I'm sorry. I didn't, I, I thought it was
gonna be something for heart attacks.
Fucking funny, right? You just stand in
there. Hey Bill, you want another rag?
You know, actually, and
just whenever you drop dead,
people laugh at first cause they think
you fucking around. Like wow man,
he really committed to
that fucking face plant
bell right now all of a sudden you
just lay in them. Alright, I'm sorry.
Oh last week. You know,
I recommend that you guys go to the
all things comedy website, you know,
for all these great podcasts
and videos and all this shit.
So of course these fucking millennials,
they get there and they just stare
at it. They're fucking overwhelmed.
So like who could you please tell me a
couple of podcasts that you like? Lou,
maybe I could look here cause I
can't do anything myself. All right.
Last week already should fear from the
skeptic tank podcast did a podcast with
comedian A. I'm going
to butcher this name.
Hormoze Rashidi that's how I'm
saying it about the Middle East.
It's hilarious and informative.
Uh, this dude was born in Iran.
So rather than listening to bill
O'Reilly talk about the Middle East,
even though he's never fucking been
there, or fucking Wolf fucking bullets,
all these talking heads
with the books, you know,
and the aligns of suits right from
the bill O'Reilly collection from the
earliest is a wolf blitzer tie, right?
Whatever the fuck it is that they do to
get the XD or extra hor money, you know,
who you think has a better walk in
closet. Bill O'Reilly, a Wolf Blitzer,
you know though, they're
fucking shiny loafers, you know,
set. Just so you know, all
their suits all lined up,
their pocket squares and all of
that shit. You know what I mean?
He fucking take you downstairs to the
wine cellar and show you these bottles of
wine that fucking hundreds of years
old. He see that, look at that.
Look at that. I get this
for lying everyday on
television. Isn't that amazing?
Come on. You do cocaine. Want
to do some coke? All right.
I'm just saying with Downey, I
just figured I'd ask you. You know,
the wife does, wife's got a rule,
no coke on the fucking main floor.
Um, anyways, I'll speak into my
wife. Oh, let me tell you my wife.
It's a rough one. You know, um,
I got this new thing that I,
that I'm into, man. And uh, you'd think
it wouldn't be a big deal. I like,
uh, I like fucking tennis
and golf shirts. I like them.
They're comfortable, they're
breathable. It's a collared shirt.
People let you into restaurants when you
wear them and she fucking hates them.
I like the Izod tennis wear.
So today I'm walking out the house to
go meet a buddy of mine and I got one of
those on and I got these fucking a,
I got these Phil Mickelson shorts,
whatever the fuck they are, just,
they're just black shorts or
whatever. So as I'm walking out,
I go, I need lcls. She goes, all right,
she goes till tiger
woods. I said, what's up?
She fucking hates how I dress. And this
is one of these things where you know,
as much as you want to remain your own
person, when you're in a relationship,
when you're the person you fucking
says you're not, you don't look good,
it affects you. But there's some I have,
this is how comfortable
these fucking shirts are.
I don't think I give a shit. I
think for the first time ever,
I don't care that my wife doesn't
approve of what the fuck I'm wearing.
They had that fucking comfortable. You
never have to iron them. They're great.
They're fucking great. So I
was a, I was at the mall there.
Um, I really should fucking,
this is just like free advertising
for all these fucking people. Um,
what's the shit that the uh,
the honor roll student wears?
What's it called? Barnet
and body armor. Yeah.
We're not taking that shit
in our house. Clothes.
Whatever was over the
top fucking sports thing.
Armor wear underarm, whatever the
fuck it is. You know what it is?
Defense shields some fucking space
odyssey shit. You know the fucking thing,
the thing that Steph curry wears
is on underarm under armor.
That's what it is. Under arm's
deodorant. Bill a under armor. Right?
They got some fucking, they got
some great clothes. So I, I knew,
I knew she didn't like that shit cause
I said to her for my birthday, I go,
I don't, I don't fucking need that.
You know what I would love
though this the summers here
and the tab is rat for
wearing some golf clothes.
Um, so I told her that,
uh, you know, I told you,
just get me a couple of those shirts
and pairs of shorts and I'll be fine.
I'll be good. She's like [inaudible]
usually she such into fashion,
she gets excited when I tell
her the clothes and you know,
my fucking birthday comes along and I
gotta tell you there was not a hint of any
of that shit. So I called her on it
like a couple of days ago. I said, hey,
you know, uh, I noticed, you know,
I asked you for those things.
They're not expensive.
You were right there and it was an easy,
it was an easy gift to
get me to pad, you know,
make it look like you actually
spent time shopping. You know,
which is why I always go and I get
her a little, some workout clothes.
That's always an extra fee. He
would go right there, friend.
Do you give him a couple more?
It looks like you give a shit,
you know more than, you know.
Not saying you don't give a shit,
but who the fuck wants to shop? Nobody.
All right. I don't want to do it,
therefore nobody wants to do it. That's
how I, that's my worldview. Okay.
I'm really starting to learn from
Trump. If I feel something then um,
everybody else also feels
it and if they don't,
then we should ram it down their
throats. It's somewhere in there.
We take their coats is,
isn't that how it works?
Have you ever seen a guy like less tough
in your life talk so fucking tough.
Like I dunno,
I don't understand why he's mistaking
having money with actually being
physically intimidating, um, with
that stupid scowl on his face.
I don't know if like Gene Simmons
had a brother that didn't make it,
that wasn't in a band.
That's what he looks like.
He looks like he's related to Gene
Simmons and he resents gene success.
Um, anyways, plowing ahead here.
So my wife fucking hates this shit.
And I called her on and I was just
going like, you didn't like that stuff,
did you? And she just fucking started
smiling and looking down at her food. And,
um, I was over there today and I,
I was gonna stop and go
in and buy some and uh,
I didn't.
And the only reason why I didn't is
because it's Sunday and it's a mall.
And um, that's just like, I
dunno, I don't know what it is.
I don't know what it is
about the weekends and malls.
Now I understand kids go in there,
teenagers going there because then you
run into other teenagers and you fucking
go like,
Hey, will you go out with me?
Do that shit. At least that's what
we did when we were of that age.
But like parents, like I just don't
understand what, why would you go there?
Especially if you get like some little
kid and you got to fucking push them
around and that damn stroller trying to
weave in and out of all those people,
I just can't imagine the fucking
misery of that, you know?
That's definitely a Wifi idea. You
know, we should go to the mall today.
I don't want to go to the mall. You know,
I have all these theories as to
why men die before women. And uh,
you know what it is. Women have to
include you in their shitty day.
You know, I fucking, um,
this my sister in law's
birthday this weekend, right?
So we ended up going to a, uh,
to a movie. I was all excited and
we saw, what did we see? We saw, uh,
independence day. Whew. It was
actually so bad. It was good.
We actually ended up having a great time
and uh, I don't wanna ruin the movie,
but like the fact that the white
guide precedent has to come back,
you know, and get shit done is
a little fucked up. You know,
Hollywood tries to be liberal, you
know, they'll have a chick president,
they'll have a black guy flying a
fucking jet and all that type of shit.
But at the end of the day,
they bring back the old founding
father to come in and save the day.
Anyway. So I had a great time doing
that. Right. So the next night, you know,
my wife's going to go meet some
friends. I think it was actually,
it was a continuation of the birthday
celebration and I was actually tired so I
wasn't going to go. So, um, I
was just like, you know what,
I'm gonna hang in. Um,
I have a ton of shit to do cause you know,
I sit in a writer's room all fucking day.
She goes, fine coat. I'm like, great,
this is perfect. I'll get a bunch
of shit done and blah, blah blah,
Blah Blah and all that type of stuff.
So right around the time it's
time for her to go right. And I'm
about ready to have a beer or anything
and she just goes, can you try me over?
She didn't say it like that, but
that's what she probably said, honey,
can you drive me over? But like,
cause I didn't want to do it.
That's what it sounded like.
And I was just like, you can't,
why don't you drive yourself over?
Just like [inaudible] me.
And so I go for fucking Uber. He's like,
put a one take me,
you know, and I, I just went like,
why can't you know I'm home?
Why do you got to drink? You're the
one who's going across fucking town.
You're going across town.
Why do I got to go across town to
you know why you don't fucking know.
Why is it the end of
the fucking day? They,
if they have a something
shitty to do, they can't do,
I can't fucking do it on their
own. Somehow you gotta be, that's,
it's like when they have a fucking kid
now they dragged the husband in there.
What the fuck is he doing in there?
What the fuck is he doing
in there? He's not a doctor.
Do you know, I know a guy went in there
where you fucking saw what was going on.
He passed out. Now they got two
patients. The fuck is that, you know?
Well, if I have to go through
the equine and well fuck it,
talk to God. Talk to God for once,
for once, for once.
This shit ran your way and
now I gotta go in there too.
So you get to hold my fucking hand and
break my God damn finger. That's fucking,
that is the defect that fucking men gave
into that shit that you got to fucking
be in there.
Is that if you were getting
fucking gallbladder surgery,
would I be standing in there
holding your fucking hand?
I don't know, but I guess if fucking
them gave him gallbladders I,
I don't know that gallbladder
kidney stones is some shit.
I guess you'd have to be. That's
the dumbest shit in the fucking,
it's the stupidest shit
ever. My wife has talked to,
if we have ever kid, you're going
to go in there. I was like no,
she got so fucking mad at me
over a hypothetical child.
You know,
if I was smart I just would've
said I'm getting smarter though.
I if I was smarter,
smart married guys go lapse allele
and I'll have to go at that. Yeah.
Yeah. [inaudible] your
way to put the baby in me.
I would fucking shit it up my ass
daddy. Thanks for you sweetheart.
Right. Oh, I'm getting heated here. Right.
I'm getting smarter though as a married
man, cause I'll tell you this right now,
the other, when we went to go
see the movie, I got there first.
Okay. And uh, I got there,
it was seven o'clock show.
I got there by like six 30 and I was like
fuck, you know I get time. Maybe I'll,
you know, it was a place to get a
sandwich. I didn't want to eat movie food.
So I got a wrap and then
they fucking had a beer too.
And by the way, I, every fucking
time I ordered this beer from Mexico,
it fucking sucks. I'm not saying all
their beer stinks, but I gotta tell Ya,
I didn't want, let me tell
you that fucking bear steaks.
I'm going to get you the
name of this right fucking,
this can be a reverse
commercial. There it is.
The fuck is that shit called Modelo.
Hang on a second. I think
that's what it's called.
It is the fucking most
bitter hoppy fucking,
it's like a job trying to get the
thing down. But I was still a beer.
So it's at the end of the day, it's
not all bad. So I'm sipping this beer,
I'm having this sandwich. I got plenty
of time to eat it. A fucking relaxed.
My wife, the lovely Nia, she, yeah, she
texts me. She goes, Hey, I'm almost there.
And I like a dope. I started
to text, Hey, I'm already here.
I mean, I'm having a
sandwich and a beer. Okay,
now this is the deal for all
you youngsters out there.
One of the things women hate the most
is when their guy is having fun without
them. All right?
So any fucking time you're having a good
time and they're not there, you gotta.
How's it gone? Eh? You know, it's kind
of crowded. Y'All always say it sucks.
Okay? If you're having
a good time, [inaudible]
fun, you're
gonna have to fucking deal with that
shit, right? This is the thing my wife is,
is, is cool as it gets. All right. I
still have to go through this shit.
So I almost fucking texted her.
I'm sitting here having a rap,
enjoying a fucking beer, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah. And then, you know what?
I was like, what the fuck am I doing
if I say this, she's going to then say,
can you get me one or she's going to
tell me to go over and go get the fucking
tickets. She's going to give me a job.
There is no fucking way she's going to
allow me to just sit here and relax and
enjoy this sandwich and this
beer that I fucking pay for.
I've worked all fucking day.
What am I a fucking asshole?
So I just erased all of it. And
rather than saying all of that,
you know, I'm on my way over here. Oh,
I'm sitting here having
a sandwich and a beer.
I erased all of that and
I just wrote, okay, send,
that was it. I didn't say I was
there. I didn't say I wasn't there.
And I sat there and I enjoyed it even
though that beer was not my favorite.
And then, um, I ended up walking over and,
uh, I ran into my sister in law
and then I, and then look at dope.
I texted my wife gone yet, I'm just uh,
you know I'm here with your sister
in law, blah blah blah, blah blah.
And then she immediately texts back,
okay, buy the tickets immediately.
Fucking is a job for you is a fucking job,
you know? And she always goes, why
Nike's trying to streamline our life?
No you're not. No you're not. You're
treating me like your fucking assistant.
I'm 37 minutes. Holy Fuck. What am
I doing here? So that's one for you.
Okay. This is what you, you kiss
him. You tell him you love him.
You tell him that beautiful every
fucking day. But I tell you this, okay,
when you're having a good
time and they're not there,
you never ever tell them you having
a good time. No fucking pictures.
None of that shit. Cause they will
sit there and they'll either, they'll,
you'll, you'll sit there,
you'll be that guy.
You know that guy on the phone while
everybody's having a good time.
The guy in the corner was on
the phone talking to his girl.
Why is he talking to his girl?
Cause he told her he was having fun.
Stupid, stupid, stupid. It's your
fucking head in the game. All right.
By the way, the Australians
are Austrian grand priests
coming up this Sunday. All right,
cause I'm going fucking nuts right
now. No Hoop, no hockey, no football.
It's driving me fucking crazy.
And the fucking goddamn Dodgers
struck up some fucking deal with,
I dunno who, I don't know
where their games are.
I don't even know if they
fucking exist anymore.
I can never watch a Dodgers game sucks.
All right. So anyways, here we go.
Dollar Shave club, everybody.
Oh Jesus. Here we go.
Um, yes.
All right, everybody.
Dollar Shave club.com delivers amazing
razors right to your door for a third of
the price of what the greedy
razor corporations chach.
That means when you
join dollar Shave Club,
you can afford to shave with a
fresh blade anytime you want,
which feels fantastic. All right,
get a first-class shave whenever
you use the executive blade.
And that's without even hurting your
wallet. And whenever you use that,
you gotta be sure to use Dr cabbies.
Z e a the blade is gently just gently
glides across your skin for the smoothest
shave ever. Shave butter isn't
your average shave cream.
It's a unique conditioning formula
with high quality natural ingredients,
leaving your skin feeling
unbelievably soft and smooth.
Now's a great time to join
Douala Shave Club. A new ramp.
Members who buy a tube of shave
butter. Dr Carver's shave butter.
Um, get a month of the
executive razor for free.
Take advantage of this
special offer today.
It's available by going to
dollar shave club.com/burr.
That's dollar shave club.com/bar height.
Dollar Shave club.com/bar.
All right is a new advertiser,
a frame bridge?
A frame bridge. Alright.
Is that any seat frame
frame bridge Cambridge is c.
R. A. M. I'm gonna say frame bridge.
They sell frames. Frame Bridge,
frame bridge. Uh,
I've got empty walls and you've got
something special you want to frame,
but you never do it because it takes
too long. It costs too much money.
I remember when cameras
weren't part of your phone. Uh,
the way we take pictures has changed,
but the way we frame them
hasn't until now. Uh,
please mention the following talking
points. I'm gonna mention all of them.
Frame Bridge. Oh, now it's spelled
with the, so it is frame, bridge frame.
bridge.com
is the easy way to frame the things you
love from the treasure trove of photos
on your phone to posters and add work.
Frame Bridge makes it easy and affordable.
Just go to frame bridge Dotcom Dude,
and pick out the frame you want or
let their designers help you choose.
You can even preview your item in any
frame slash style, any frame style. Sorry.
They'll send an you a prepaid
package to ship your items safely.
Or you can simply upload a picture
to frame bridge site or app.
You can even upload a picture
directly from the Instagram.
How fucking easy is that?
The expert team frame bridge.
We'll custom frame your items in
days, not weeks or months in days,
and deliver your finished
piece directly to your door.
Ready to hang in style
called frame bridge.
The genius site that makes custom framing
easy frame bridge offers a happiness
guarantee.
Their team gives each item personal
care and attention because meeting your
expectation is as important
as meeting their own.
Instead of hundreds of do all this,
you'd paid at a framing store,
their prices start at just 39 bucks
and all shipping is free. All right?
Right now you go to frame bridge.com
F R A M E B R I d g e frame and bridge
frame,
bridge.com and use Promo Code burr and
you'll save an additional 15% off your
first order. Just go to frame
bridge.com Promo Code Bar frame,
bridge.com Promo Code Burn. All
right, we got two more here.
MVMT watches when you're in your early
twenties and thirties money can be tight,
so that was a lot of other stuff
that gross bill. All right.
If you're not careful,
dressing well can quickly drain your bank
account like spending 400 to $500 on a
department store. Watch.
Why would you do that?
There's some brands out there charging
insane prices for watches that aren't
even worth it. Well, if you want to
look great without when you go out,
but still have enough money to buy
him or her a drink, checkout movement,
watches.com all right,
these watches is shap originally
founded by two broke college kids.
Um, I never understand that.
Like they had no money and then they
started a watch company with what money.
What collateral? Uh, so you have no
money and you start a watch company.
All right.
Movement watches cut out the middleman
and their big brand retail markups in
order to give you a stylish wash.
Watch for an affordable price move and
watch it start at just 95 bucks a watch
what the spa department store
quality for a fraction of the price.
There's sleek and minimalistic. Sorry,
talking to him through a yawn here.
A modern twist on a classic style
movement has grown organically purely by
supporters like you.
So join there more than 1 million social
media followers and get a movement.
Watch today. Go to M v empty
watches. That's Michael Vincent,
Michael Thomas,
watches.com/burr and they'll give
you 15% off your entire purchase.
MVMT watches.com/burn and
lastly, but not leastly
stamps.com they got the quickest
and the tightest fucking copy in the
advertising game. Watch
how quickly this goes.
Trips to the post office had
become second nature to you.
They seem easy because you've been doing
your mailing and shipping that way for
so long. But think about all the
hassle, man. Dropping what you're doing,
driving there, finding parking,
waiting. There's a much better way.
stamps.com stamps.com is the easy and
convenient way to get postage right from
your desk.
Buy and print official US postage
using your own computer and printer.
They make it easy to get exact
postage for any letter, any package,
any class of mail, the instant
you need it. No expenses.
Expensive postage, meters to lease
and no more trips to the post office.
She got to try it. I use it
anytime I send out my posters.
I'm a more on if I can
figure out. So can you.
So sign up for stamps.com
and use my last name Bar,
but this special four
week trial offer, uh,
plus $110 bonus offer that includes
postage and a digital scale. Do not wait.
Go to stamps.com before you
do anything else, click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandyoutypeinburrthatstamps.com
and
[inaudible].
All right, mercifully that's over. Yeah,
advertising is all right. Where the
fuck is the reeds for this week?
Um, okay. Lab grown food.
All right. Hey Bill, wondering if
you've heard of lab grown meats.
Basically scientists have figured out
a way to make plants tastes like meat.
Why aren't they fucking
with the food supply?
I don't understand what they're doing.
This could eliminate our need to raise
and kill millions of cows a year and help
stop the ass gas coming from these cows
from continuing to ruin our planet.
I'm not sure how I feel about
it, but I like the idea of it.
Here's an example from the article.
The impossible burger is more than
just peas and carrots smashed together.
It's the result of some
pretty high tech research.
Brown's team analyzes meat at a molecular
level to determine what makes a burger
tastes smell and cook the way it does.
He wants his burger to be
squishy while raw gross.
Then from up and Brown on the grill,
he believes everything from an animal,
from an animals fat tissue to muscle
cells can be replicated using plant
compound compounds. Before
starting the company,
Brown had a hunch that a certain
ingredient made meat tastes different than
other foods.
I had a strong suspicion early on that
I don't want to say that h e m e him
would be the magic ingredient
for flavor, not hemp.
A said Brown. Here's a link to the whole
article. Would you eat this? Thanks.
Come back to Boston. No, I try not
to fuck with that type of shit. No,
I would not eat that. If I want meat,
I eat meat. If I want ice cream,
I get ice cream. I don't get low fat
ice cream. I don't try to eat ice cream.
That doesn't make me fat cause you're
gonna pay the price somehow. All right.
And the reason why there's so many
fucking cows shitting and farting into the
fucking air is because there's so many
people. The problem, time and time again,
there's too many fucking people. That
is the fucking problem. So, okay,
we all switch to these fucking plants,
then what are we gonna do then?
We're gonna need all this water
to grow all these fucking plants.
We are too much of a fucking burden on
the natural resources of this planet.
We need to thin the fucking herd.
That's the deal. That's it, everybody.
If you want a kid, you have
one too, at the fucking most.
So you know you're not creating more
people than there is you. Right?
But that workout, no,
that wouldn't work out because
then they both have two than you.
Two people and the who then go create
two each. Now it keeps getting bigger.
One Kid, right? Everybody has one kid,
two creates one and another
to meet and they create one.
That's the only way to reverse.
Fuck our way out of this thing.
And if you never have kids, you ought to
get some sort of massive tax break. Um,
I think that that's what you should do.
So then scientists don't have to sit
around and like, you know, well, you know,
at some point there's going to be no more
state cause there's gonna be too many
fucking people. You know, I don't
wanna live on a planet with no steak,
you know,
and I would like to go back to just
the way cow has just sort of ran around
chickens ran around then every,
I don't know where he just gave me all
right there for it as opposed to I having
miserable lives, you know? I don't
know. Anyways, let's blow ahead.
I don't know how I feel
about the whole fuck.
I fucking love animals and I hate when
people torture them and treat them like
shit and all that. I also like eating
them. I love chicken. I love steaks.
I love fish. I like all that
shit. So like, you know,
if we could just get somebody to get out
from underneath these corporation cons
and just get everybody on the
same page and be like, look,
this is what we're doing.
Okay, this is the problem.
This is what everybody needs to do to
try to at least keep it at bay, you know?
But there's none of that, you know what
I mean? It's just this, I don't know.
It doesn't come from the right
fucking people. All right.
Getting through college.
Fuck a Mr Burr. Um,
how do I get through this college shit.
I'm currently taking anatomy
and physiology one in the
summer since they failed
it and it fucking blows ass.
But why are you taking it?
Did you ever feel like when
you were going to college,
you just couldn't do it because maybe
there was that one class that was
impossible to pass? If so, how
did you get through it? You know,
it's hard for me to even imagine
passing this class ever getting a,
I didn't know what that it,
I can't even say at k I n.
E s I ology kinesiology degree.
Same kinesiology. Sam Kinison
degree. Thanks by the way. Uh,
I saw on your Wikipedia page that
you died and I felt horrible.
I know you don't care, but just thought
I'd tell you. Oh, you know. Well,
that's good. Well, I guess I don't have
to pay taxes this year. Um, anyways.
Uh, all right.
Do you ever think that you're in the
wrong major or maybe you're in the wrong
school? Like life shouldn't
be that fucking hard dude.
It's not like you're dumb if you
taking these kinds of classes. Um,
I would say that, um,
the turning point in my college career
was when I decided that I wanted to be a
standup comedian and, um,
I still wanted to get a college
degree for whatever reason.
It was important to my
parents and I don't know,
I just want to be a college
graduate. I don't know why. Um,
so I got out of the college I was at
and I transferred to Emerson College,
which was more of a performance school
and people made movies and it was acting
and radio and all of this shit. And, uh,
all of a sudden my grades went up
cause I was doing shit that I was into,
um, there, but there was a couple
of fucking classes that just sucked.
There's always going to be a couple
of those. How do you get through,
you know what you do? Don't blow
it off cause if it's already hard,
you get three days behind
in that thing. It's,
it's going to be like being
a month behind four years.
So what I would do is I would just
stay on that shit and just be like,
all right. Plus Dude, this taken
over the summer as a joke. Dude,
it's practically impossible. You know,
I was so old by the time I
fucking graduated college,
like Matt transferred to
Emerson. I was like, I forget,
I was almost 23 years old and I was
still just beginning my sophomore year.
I transferred there in
January of whatever year. Um,
by December of the following year
I had done three years of college.
I just fucking, I just,
I just said fuck this.
And I did. I finished my sophomore
year, the January to April.
And then in the summer I picked
up a semester. So I finished that.
Then the next year was my junior year
and then I went to summer school again,
picked up another semester. And then the
following fall was my second semester,
my senior year. And that was it.
I gave it the old right there,
Fred and fucking out of here.
But what you have to do is when you're
going straight through like that,
or if you're doing like the summertime
shit is, you got to stay on it.
Just treat it like a fucking job.
It's actually a good exercise.
It's something that sucks. It's something
that you hate and you just, you know,
rather than running from just turn around
and face it and get through it if this
is the degree you want. Um, but
sometimes if it's that fucking hard,
it means that you're a square peg trying
to go into a round hole and you need to
go after what you really want
to fucking do. Cause you know,
when you do what you want to do, you have
a passion for it and it's, it's easy.
Um,
cheap hill. That was original.
Well, whatever that, that it fit,
that advice fit. Alright. Would
you consider a Vegas residency,
a deer country, McCann face at this
point in your career? If offered,
would you accept a comedy residency in
Las Vegas or would you be offended as
there's plenty of life in that old
dog yet? If not, how bad would you,
your career have to be going before you
accepted and which hotel would you like
to work in next time you
come to Australia? Play a Gig
in, uh, Adelaide. I Dunno,
we're not all backwards Fox. I mean,
I never thought you were take it easy,
your cunt. Um, what I do
that well, I couldn't,
well if I didn't have efforts
for family or anything like that,
um, I don't think that that's for,
I think my ACC would dry up if
I just stayed in the same venue.
Um, [inaudible]
having said that, the way
you're, the way you're, uh,
framing that Gig as if it's a sad
thing that happens to comedians do,
those are multimillion dollar contracts.
And, um,
anybody who's ever done one of those,
as long as they didn't go to the crap
table after this show every night,
uh,
rides off into the sunset,
like with bags and bags of cash.
Um,
that's just something that I have no
interest in at this point in my career and
doing, I still like traveling
in that type of stuff.
I do have to tell you though,
um,
if she, if it just wasn't Vegas, it just,
that town does nothing for me just
sitting there in the fucking desert.
I would go nuts. But I do have to
say that, you know, if I could,
okay.
You know, all of a sudden
just get off the road.
I totally understand why comedians
do that after a while. Um,
all right. So there you go. All right.
And I'll, I'll tell you fucking town.
I'll try to get close to it
next time. All right. Okay.
Built getting people you hate fired.
All right, this already sounds evil.
Hey Bill, love your shit.
I'm almost 30 mistakes are made
and now I work at a shit factory.
I shovel literal shit with a pay loader,
a for about 10 hours a
day, which isn't so bad,
but it's made worse by my terrible
coworkers. It's a small operation.
Everyone is about twice my age and for
the most part they are pretty average
blue collar guys. We all hate our
boss and his yes man. Aaron boy,
a about Aaron boy. He's the
kind of guy who is always right.
Uh, done his way. Run and tell the
boss what the rest of us are doing.
Rat bastard tight. All right. Uh,
he's also the kind of guy who says
the n word to let the rest of us know.
He's a no guff taking no
shits given type of guy.
He's not, uh,
he's white as the driven snow and think
he's Indian because he purchased a tee
shirt at Walmart and
with wolves on it too.
This is fucking pretty random so
far. Well today I took my stand.
I snitched to human resources.
A you fucking rat bastard.
He goes, I told them how one
black employee knows Erin.
Boy, a racist
to you. You're pumped. You
have no punctuation in this.
Okay,
this is the thing I, you know,
I didn't like how in the beginning
you just fucking played the victim.
Like I'm almost 30 mistakes were made
and now I work at a shit factory.
Like you just glossed over all your stuff
and then you saying you got terrible
coworkers
or, well, what about, what
are you, what about you?
You fucking off a punctuation
here. Mistakes were made.
Mistakes are continuing to be made, sir.
All right, let me try and get through.
I told them how one our one black employee
knows Aaron boys are racist and that
he's pissed. I also told them
about the weird sexual shit.
He says like fisting his girlfriend.
All of this is true and the,
the guy's a complete asshole who knows
the boss won't fire him and he takes
complete advantage of that
by making our lives. Hell.
Is this like animal house is the
guys named Niedermeyer. Anyway,
I come home and smoke some weed because
that's what you do when you shovel shit
and now I'm feeling shitty myself. I
hate the guy and I really hate my boss.
But sure enough, human resources called
me and I could sense their panic.
My money's on their fire on they're
firing him. Everyone else at work,
once I'm gone and is hoping he gets
fired. But now I'm starting to feel bad.
He's an asshole who I hate and I
feel like I'm sticking it to the man,
but that I go too far. I don't,
I'm not big on rat and people
out to be honest with you. Um,
was there a way that you could have
gone to him and just said, hey, listen,
not for nothing. I don't want to listen
to you dropping the n word. You know,
and I don't want to listen to you talking
about fists and your girlfriend that
has nothing to do with the job. Okay.
And then he would make your life
unbelievably and, and then I would, I,
that's what you should've done. You
should have [inaudible] come in.
All you guys should have
just approached him, right?
Like Mickey Rourke at the end of
Pope Bridge of Greenwich Village,
cause of f tape. I took off
a fucking dead cop. Right.
You'd just come up to him and just
say, listen, here's the deal. Okay,
you're still our supervisor,
but no longer are you dropping the n
word and no longer you talking about fist
and your girlfriend around us.
We don't want to hear it anymore.
You understand us? If you do, we're
going to human resources. All right?
A fucking creepy name. Human Resource.
So fucking disgusting. Yeah, that's
what you should have done. But you know,
you live and you learn. This guy sounds
like a condo. You know what I mean? Uh,
just do that in the future. Oh. And
then you could say, and by the way,
if you try to get any of his
fired, that's going down too.
So basically what we're saying is you've
lost all control to intimidate us now.
Uh, but we'll still do what you say.
As long as you're not a, all right,
go fuck yourself. Run A lot. Uh,
why don't you do that? You
like what I just pitched there.
That's like when the cast of friends all
got together and negotiated together,
right? They got their money. You
could do that at your shit factory.
All right. Laying off the
booze. Hey, Billy blunts.
After hearing you talk about drying out,
you really inspired me to do the same.
I drank entirely too much. Right now after
about eight days of daily commitment,
I'm up to about a half a fifth
a day with the odd beer mixed in
a wait. I thought you said
after about eight years
of daily commitment.
I thought that eight days I thought he
was like drying out and then all of a
sudden he's boosting that
confused me. All right.
After about eight years
of daily commitment,
I'm up to about half a fifth a
day and with an odd beer mixed in.
I know it's a lot,
but I've worked up my tolerance so much
that I don't really get drunk anymore.
I just lose an hour here and
there. No big deal, right? Yeah.
The two that's called
blacking out. Anyways,
I was able to quit smoking weed after
five years of heavy daily use. No problem.
I was even able to quit using oxycotton
Jesus after about three years of eating
and sniffing pills all damn day.
I've been able to maintain a normal
life while going through these ups and
downs. I'm married with a kid
and a house and a great job.
If you make more than a million dollars,
I probably manage your retirement account,
but despite being able to
put the hard shit down,
boos has been the hardest so far.
Last week I decided to jump off the
wagon with you. It's been hard as hell,
but I've been able to stick
to it better than I ever had.
I'm trying to limit beers to two a day
and only drink liquor on the weekends.
I've slipped once, but I'm doing my
fucking best. I don't have a question.
More of a requests. Please keep
us updated on your progress.
It's helping me with my own journey
because none of my friends really drink at
all much less the way I do and my wife
doesn't even know the extent of my issue,
which is an issue on its own. Yeah, it is.
It makes my struggle a bit easier to
hear you having the same troubles as, um,
I have was sticking, uh, to my resolution.
Thanks for giving me the kick in the
ass. I need to get my shit together.
All right, two, this is what
you need to do. All right.
After just saying don't text your
wife that you have in a good time,
you got to let you know. You gotta
let your wife know about this.
This is a major thing.
You're not sitting there eating a fucking
Turkey rep having a fucking bitter
Mexican beer. Whatever the
fuck it was called. Um,
I would talk to her about it because
then she can, she can watch it. Dude.
I can't fucking watch it. I
can't, I can't do this for you.
You need to have your wife involved
in this and just say, listen,
I've been drinking entirely
too much and I need your help.
All right,
so, um,
I gotta be honest with you, dude. I
try. Like right now I have a beer a day.
And that's the only,
because my wife had some people over and
they left a bunch of beer in the fridge
and it's taken up all this space and
I don't want to dump it down the sink,
you know, I'm not dumping out a bunch
of beers. I just have one a day.
And what sucks is that corona light,
which are fucking horrific. Um,
so I don't even enjoy them. Um,
but I just have like one a day. Uh,
but last night, you know, it
was Saturday night, I'm home,
you know, I got the best
fucking bar in town,
I got high end booze and you know,
I had a couple of home pores,
which know, as I've mentioned
before, there's the bar pour in,
there's the home pour.
Cause you can lie to yourself that
you have in two scotches a night.
But you know, when you go out to a bar
and you see what their scotches are,
you like, oh wait, did I
say two? I met nine. Um,
so, uh, yeah, like last night,
you know, I had a couple of two,
three of those after having the beer
during the day and I woke up today,
I felt like I got hit by a
truck, you know, it was awful.
I walked my dog around the block and I
shook it off and I was just like, like,
you know what it is at nighttime, it's
brutal. Being sober at night sucks,
but being sober in the
waking up the next day,
stone sober is the greatest. It's, it,
it feels better than getting shit faced.
Um, so, you know, and my wife, you know,
she stays on me. She stays
on me about it. It's weird.
Like I don't want like you sound
like, you know, you've, you,
you've had some Harcourt. Luckily I
don't have like an addictive personality.
My thing is I have time,
I have free fucking time
and I get into like,
and I am a creature of habit. Like if
I can't, if I like, this is how I work.
Like if I was to go out and buy a
fucking pint of ice cream, right.
And I was the wolf, that fucking thing
down one night, I would start doing that.
That's what I would do. So
like if I, you know, and,
and all these fucking addicts
who go to AA and all that shit,
they always trying to make
sure that they try to make,
like everybody's a fucking
addict, you know, I'm not dude,
I don't have like a fucking bottle in
the back of my fucking toilet and shit
sitting there shaken drink and fucking
mouthwash and shit. You know what I mean?
I just like drinking. I enjoy it, you
know what I mean? But as I get older,
like just paying for it the next day
is making it not fucking worth it.
So I just don't do it. And
whenever I decide to stop,
I just stop and it sucks for a few days
and then what it is is it's not part of
my daily routine and then I
literally just forget about it.
Um,
okay.
You know, but I don't know, you seem
like a little bit, uh, beyond that.
So I would definitely reach
out to you, your wife and uh,
see if she can help you and
maybe if she can help you,
you stop there and if you need more
help, I would go do that. But, uh,
don't depend on me because I don't have
any kids and I live like a fucking 14
year old, so I'm not a good person
to use. I mean, having said that,
I'm just doing a bare day if
that helps you. All right.
Okay. S t d o Jesus.
S t doe Jesus. Alright, Bill
Billy, what's that red mark?
I don't know what that means.
Is that something else I need to
be self conscious about? All right.
This is a gnarly one. Um, I
recently found out that I have
HPV Aka genital awards and he then he
says gross. Uh, it's actually very
common and it's just a few small bumps,
but it fucking sucks anyways.
It can show up f years
after you've received it.
So I have no idea who I got
it from. And once again,
another great reason to get married
to stay out of that fucking world.
Here's my question. I
recently met an amazing girl.
We have a lot of the same interests.
She's a hard 10, Yada, Yada, Yada.
Point is, I really like her.
I'm getting treated for the HPV,
but I respect her enough to
tell her of the risks. Uh,
she's getting into in the case,
in case it goes that far. So Bill,
how do I tell her that I have an STD and
that there's a small chance she could
get it? Uh, I don't want to
mess up this opportunity,
but my other options are basically to
move to a cabin in the woods for six
months until this is completely gone. Uh,
thought it'd be funny to hear your
advice. Oh Dude, fuck you. Yeah,
you've got to tell her totally 100% teller
and then just don't just say, listen.
So I can't do anything for six months
other than to get to know you better.
You know? And this is the thing,
if she doesn't want to stick
around for that gay, God bless her.
Who gives a fuck? You know what I
mean? You got to look at it like,
well what else wouldn't she stick
around for it? But then again,
you're also coming out of the gate
saying, you gotta fucking STDA. You know,
there's no right or wrong
answer other than to not,
you got to tell people
that shit, you know,
don't you watch the person that
had it told you? You don't want it.
You don't want, you ain't gotta.
You gotta break the chain there.
Women are so much more
advanced emotionally,
so much more. They understand
love, they understand emotions,
they understand so much more than guys do.
And it's not our fault.
It's not their fault the way that
they are and all that type of shit.
It's just how we're fucking wired.
I don't fucking understand it. Um,
it is what it is. But I, you know,
if she really likes you
and she's understanding,
and then you're sitting there
saying, you know, if she's a hard 10,
people are trying to fuck her all the
time. So you're gonna be going like,
listen, here's something embarrassing,
but it's going to be cleared up in six
months and I respect you enough to tell
you, you know, we can hang out,
get to know each other better and
all that type of stuff. But you know,
there's no way I'm having
sex with you or anybody else.
You'll come off responsible.
You'd come off as honest.
And if that's what the fuck she's
looking for, she'll stick around.
If she doesn't, then fucking
lay low for six months.
Lay Low for fucking six months
and then, you know, whatever,
go to the gym and get fucking
shredded. No, don't do that.
You'll get more ladies coming
up to you. Stay away. Um,
anyways, let's, uh, let's,
uh, let, let me, uh,
let me finish off this fucking
podcast. What are we up to here?
Hour and eight minutes. All right.
Is there anything else I
wanted to talk about? Oh,
okay. Fucking Billy red faces. Uh,
finally gonna get himself a car.
Okay.
I'm gonna order it this fucking week
cause they don't have the color that I
want.
And if I'm going to buy a new car or
Frugal Freddy's getting the fucking color
that he wants and I'm not going to
tell you guys what kind of car that I'm
getting because I, cause I
want to enjoy the process.
I don't want listen to who to
bug you. Good yet with pull.
You fucking get this one.
You go get the one you want.
But I fucking looked at everything.
I looked at the January,
I looked at the fuck, I looked
at a BMW, I looked at Alexis,
I decided that I want one of those fucking
four doors sedans at fucking cruises.
Um, I found the BMW to
basically be a, you know,
I love the German,
like push precision and
precision back at my kids.
Say that precision. There you go.
But I don't think I can speak. Um,
you know, you could just sit in
there and you just fill the German.
All of it's no wasted movement. CF,
this suspension as stiff as
he wants a comfortable ride,
you get the seven series. Um,
I looked at Alexis, I
don't like that grill.
It looks like Darth Vader's mouth
on his fucking helmet. And um,
I dunno. I Dunno. I think
I found the one though. Oh,
I, I literally looked at
everything. Mercedes, BMW, Jaguar,
Lexus, the whole fucking thing. You know,
I'm not getting the sick ass model.
I'm getting the one debt decking
debt has the right and this is what,
this is what I'm going to get a four
door sedan that has the biggest fucking
engine I in, in the, that I
can get in it, right? And,
but I'm not going to buy a high end car
so I can still take it to the fucking
grocery store. And when some
fucking opens that in my car,
it's not going to kill
me. You know what I mean?
Cause I don't get,
I just don't understand having a
high end car like psycho high end.
Like I'm buying a mid range, you know,
car, Amy,
all of them seem fucking high end to
me because I've driven a Prius for nine
fucking years. Do you guys know I'm on
my fourth car of my life? That's all.
I had an 83 Ford ranger. Then I
had this funny, I bought a used,
I bought that used. I drove that
for fucking 10 years and then,
and then it burned down to the side of
the road. That's a long fucking story.
Then I bought a a
in like 96 at 97 I bought
a 1988 Honda accord.
Four to a five speed.
Fucking love that car.
And it was the top of the line, Honda
accord, the DX, whatever the fuck it was.
It was fun. That was a
great fucking car. Um,
and then I got a, then I moved back
to New York, so I didn't need a car.
Wait a minute. Yeah. And then I bought
my Prius and then I got the f 100.
That's all I've had. That's
pretty fucking good. Right?
Almost 50 fucking years old. I've
been driving since 1984 Jesus Christ,
mom and driving for 32 fucking years.
I've had basically, I've had three cars,
right? One, two, three, four, four cars.
That's pretty fucking good. How frugal,
Freddie. So I've had enough of
the Prius and I had enough of it.
You know what's funny about that car?
Cause it's a Toyota and I've changed
the oil and I've maintained it and
everything.
Like there is a major part of me that
wants to drive that car for the rest of my
fucking life.
Cause it's hilarious to me because I
know I could get a million miles out of
that car because at the end of the day
all these fucking dopes whose cars shit
the bed unless like you remember like
the BMWs a few years ago when they were
just designed to fall apart
at 50 to 60,000 miles. Um,
you know, unless it's being done on
purpose, at the end of the fucking day,
the engine block, it's made
out of fucking steel like that.
That thing's not supposed. You're not
supposed to have any problems with that.
That thing. In theory,
all of that Shit's should last for
fucking ever granted thing here.
Thing there will come loose or something
like that. But the engine itself,
when people just have the,
when your engine is just
fried, the valves are fried.
And all that shit. You weren't
maintained in the fucking car.
And for the life of me now when you
can go to all of these fucking places,
I still never go to Jiffy Lube. I
still take it to the dealership. Um,
Jiffy lube cause it's so
getting in and out of there.
I always get nervous as you always
see those stories that, you know,
they drain the oil out and
they forget to put it back in.
Basically the poltergeist, you know,
you move the headstones but
you didn't move the bodies.
It's basically the car version of that.
Like they take the fucking
oil out and you know,
whoever's supposed to put it in up top
doesn't do it. The guy down the bottom,
it's, he just drains
the fucking oil. Right?
Then he puts the plug back in and
then he's got the fucking grease gun.
He lubes the chassis all up,
hits all the points. Right?
Like he fucking knows like he even
knows what model you have and where,
where they all are. Right?
He's just fucking looking
for those plugs to fill up.
Right. And meanwhile, some other con at
the top is supposed to drop, you know,
four, five, six quartz, oil, whatever
it takes to the top of your engine.
And sometimes they forget, then you
drive away, right? And then we'll,
then when are you going to do,
you're going to go down there and
they're not going to give you your,
they're going to give you the amount
of money that your car is worth,
which is the total fuck over. Right?
Cause if it's a, you know, like my car, I,
I can't imagine what my
car is worth right now.
I mean it has to be
worth like maybe $1,200.
But the thing is, is for me to replace
it to go out by another car. I mean, I,
I can't buy a $1,200 fucking
car. You see what I'm saying?
So I was taken down to the
goddamn dealership. So anyways,
I don't know what the
fuck I'm talking about.
Some weeks I got diarrhea of the mouth
and this is fucking one of them. Um,
that's it for the podcast.
I'm still trying to figure out a
way to bring a couple of listeners.
I decided that a, a contest isn't
the right fucking way to do it.
Um, I want to have a couple of podcasts,
maybe a couple of two, three podcasts.
Listeners come in for
the final table read, um,
of the year provided you don't tell
everybody what happened in the script,
which could also be a fucking problem.
I think this whole idea was stupid.
I think it was a stupid idea. You
know what? Fuck that. You know what?
Fuck it that offers off the table.
I'm sorry. I just, this day and age,
everybody's gonna fucking go high.
I won't fucking say anything.
And then you know what? They're
going, they're going to go right away.
And what did she do after
all the yeah, yet bullshit.
You're gonna go right fucking down. You're
going to fuck me over. I know things.
It's too much of a risk. I'll come up
with something else. Alright, here we go.
Hour and 15 minutes. Say you
go, you guys enjoy your Monday,
you're fucking cunts and a, I'll
check in on you on Thursday. Um,
I have put guys, have a nice couple
of days there. All right. See Ya.